well we know this is a very big
political deal the first
post-brexit trade deal but what kind of
an impact is it going to have
for all of us well the short answer is i
can't really tell you for sure because
we've only had
a few details released by the government
stuff like this they've said that the
impact for families in terms of cheaper
bills there's going to be 34 million
pounds
a year sounds a lot doesn't it but then
divide it by the number of households
around the country
and you get that figure instead one
pound 22 uh per household nor point
naught
naught four percent uh of total spending
so not all that much
but really the key thing with these kind
of deals is to look at the big picture
and here's
the big picture historically when it
comes to trade with australia going all
the way back to the 19th century
and what you can see is the higher these
lines are the more we're trading with
australia
and there was the peak back at world war
ii even in the 1950s about one in eight
of all of our
uh exports and indian imports we're
going to are coming from australia but
then they've come down quite a lot it
wasn't just joining the eu
but they've come down to a very low
level recently and so the question with
this deal is whether it moves those
lines
upwards and the big thing in this deal
certainly when it comes to goods
is agriculture trade tariff-free
quota-free access
for agriculture that could be a really
big deal and i'll show you why we'll
look
at the total amount of trade when it
comes to beef and lamb and mustang
coming from australia
and the key thing here is there are
quotas right now so a kind of limit on
how much can be imported
of those things before those tariffs
starts to kick in
and look at what's happening to those
quotas the government said it's going to
go up gradually but just look at those
lines i'm going to show you what happens
the minute this trade deal is signed
they go up really sharply there's a big
gap isn't there a big jump in those
quotas and then after 10 years they go
up
even higher really high to the extent
that you remember
you saw that chart a moment ago about
those kind of glory days of the 1950s
australia
uk trade we're talking about similar
levels in terms of those quotes after 10
years
similar levels even higher when it comes
to lamb and mutton so that could be a
really big deal
for uk farmers and indeed australian
farmers in exchange for that might look
like a concession
the uk has got something quite
significant though when it comes to
immigration brits under 35 are going to
be able to
travel in australia work in australia
for three years was two previously
few restrictions and australians are no
longer going to be prioritized
that is a really big deal indeed like i
say but so too are those agricultural
concessions